We Begin the day with the two threats to
the World As We Know It that according
to the Biden Administration today U.S
President Biden released his National
Security strategy a prediction of
geopolitics for the near and long term
through Washington's eyes
China stands out as the biggest
challenge to the international order the
White House says that Beijing is intent
on spreading its model of authoritarian
Rule and that it is quickly achieving
the economic and military power needed
to turn plans into action but in the
immediate future the U.S sees Russia as
the biggest threat one that needs to be
contained through a unified front that
is the message delivered today in
Brussels where NATO members are meeting
along with 50 other countries committed
to helping Ukraine here is the U.S
defense secretary Lloyd Austin
and in the past few days Putin has given
us all
another Grim preview of a future
in which the appetites of aggressive
autocrats outweigh the rights of
peaceful States
but we're going to do everything we can
as fast as we can to help the Ukrainian
forces get the capability they need to
protect the Ukrainian people that's very
very important to us we would all be
less secure
in a world where big powers can assault
their peaceful neighbors and trample
their borders by force
well that NATO meeting taking place as
Russian airstrikes in Ukraine continue
more civilian targets were destroyed
today the third consecutive day of
massive aerial assaults on the country a
strike on a crowded Market killed at
least seven people in the town of of
dika in the Eastern donesk region the
governor there saying none of the
targets had any military purpose
the Kremlin says that these latest
airstrikes are retaliation for an
explosion last weekend on the only
Bridge connecting Russia with occupied
Crimea today Moscow said that it has
detained eight suspects connected to
what it is calling a ukrainian-backed
terrorist attack
Security Service says these people
include five Russians three Ukrainian
and three Armenian citizens Kiev has not
claimed responsibility for the blast and
has called moscow's investigation
nonsense
well there are a lot of moving parts to
this conflict tonight that's why we are
happy to welcome Jade McLean to the show
she is a senior researcher at the
Monterey initiative in Russian studies
she joins me tonight from Oxford in the
UK it's good to have you
on the program of the U.S and NATO are
pushing this message that Vladimir Putin
is running out of options and that he's
running out of time is he
thank you for having me is he running
out of time no I don't think he is
running out of time and I don't think
that's really something that
um will depend on on NATO of the US I
think he is slightly I think what's
probably most of the point is that he's
running out of options
um and I think that's a much more
difficult one because he hasn't really
left himself much space to to turn
around or to back out especially since
he declared partial mobilization so I
think he has time but I don't think he
has options when you talk about options
I mean what would those options be right
now
right now there's the obvious option of
well not obvious but um the rather
horrific option that everybody is
discussing which is the nuclear option
which I think is very very unlikely but
of course must must remain on
everybody's radar for perfectly with
self-explanatory reasons
um the other options appear to would of
course be that he somehow backs down or
turns around or starts putting out
feelers for negotiations however I think
his break with reality or is such that
it's very difficult it's very difficult
for him to come up with anything that
would be acceptable and there's no way
that he's prepared the Russian people if
anything the propaganda and
um the sort of loud figures um in Russia
are preparing are trying to to whip up
further War hysteria among the the
Russian population so it's it's very
difficult I think there's a tendency
sometimes in the west to think that okay
Putin is this dictator who says oh this
is how I want it and that's how it will
be and that's not the case at all
let me ask you about the situation for
for the the Ukrainian military
um air defense systems from the U.S and
now from Germany are now in Ukraine
last night there was a Ukrainian
lawmaker here on this program and she
told me that these deliveries
are too little too late she still wants
a no-fly zone over Ukraine which we know
that the U.S president has said is not
going to happen is she right though that
the air defense weapons are not enough
I think sadly Monday showed that the
attacks um on on Kiev and on other
cities I think they showed that clearly
Ukraine needs to have a head defense my
understanding is that there are certain
technologies that could be useful I know
that people talk about the fact that
Israel's Iron Dome technology wouldn't
be
um appropriate but I think there are
other forms of air defense technology
that that I know Israel has that that
would be that would be useful but of
course
um that's that's really a bilateral
issue
um rather than rather than a um a sort
of NATO allies and and Ukraine
discussion but I know there is there's
plenty that um that could still be sent
and and personally I hope it is because
whilst I completely understand that a
no-fly zone is it worked bluntly it's
not enforceable because it would involve
NATO planes shooting down Russian planes
and
um that is just too escalatory
um I do think that there are other ways
that we could help help Ukraine to
protect its skies and we should do we
should do everything short of something
that could very reasonably sparkly a
wall and there is of course you know a
lot of hope that this war will have a an
end sooner rather than later and we just
heard yesterday that Vladimir Putin may
be open to a one-on-one meeting with
President Biden at the G20 Summit next
month now this news coming from the
Russian foreign minister and not from
the U.S or from the West
is this do you think an attempt to
create that off-ramp for Vladimir Putin
and it and if it is I mean it would be
coming from the Russians what and
instead of coming from the the evil West
as they have said
well we've seen some interesting
some interesting things Outreach haven't
we really from the Kremlin recently
including the the Elon Musk tweets
um which were very much commented on and
and now this sort of signaling of an
openness to to a meeting
um I would note that that Biden has shot
down that well it was a bad choice of
words that Biden has refused that
opportunity I think unless it were to
discuss um uh U.S prisoners some who are
currently held in in Russia
in terms of an off ramp I think
clearly the war is not going well for
Russia but
the sorts of things that Putin is
insisting on you know the recognition
that these four territories plus Crimea
belong to is it so her son zaparisia
Donetsk and luhansk regions plus Crimea
all belong to Russia and that Ukraine
will take on some sort of neutral status
they're really just non-starters and I
think we have to really be careful here
as well as as sort of Western countries
to remember that
ukrainians have agency in this too and
really ukrainians right now are not are
not negotiating I think every single
Publishers that you mentioned the Tesla
CEO Elon Musk he is denying a report
that he spoke directly with Vladimir
Putin recently about the war in Ukraine
and about a proposed peace plan
um he's denying that because the
political scientist Ian bremmer who has
often been a guest here on this program
Ian has said that musk told him that he
had spoken recently with Putin and this
has created a Twitter storm I want to
show you this thread from Ian Bremer
earlier today from the Eurasia group he
tweeted this Elon Musk told me that he
had spoken with Putin and the Kremlin
directly about Ukraine he also told me
that the kremlin's red lines or what
they are these red lines for the
equivalent he then tweeted again
I have been writing my Weekly Newsletter
on geopolitics for 24 years I write
honestly without fear or favor in this
week's update was no different followed
by I've long admired musk as a unique
and world-changing entrepreneur which
I've said publicly he's not a
geopolitics expert and then you had Elon
Musk himself weighing in tweeting simply
nobody should trust Bremer
now we brought this up because in a
tweet just last week musk laid out a
Ukraine Russia peace plan that has the
exact same terms as the one that Bremer
says musk told him that he got from
Vladimir Putin I mean this is the
world's richest man he admits that he
has spoken with Vladimir Putin he speaks
with the U.S President Biden is there a
musk factor in this conflict and should
the ukrainians be worried about it
I think the ukrainians should take note
of it given the importance of starlink
um which which comes from which
obviously is something that musk um uh
controls and owns the importance of
styling to keeping the Ukrainian Army
sort of connected and and networked
within
um in in their fight against Russia so I
think they do too let me just the star
leakage of course is um internet access
via satellites also which uh musk owns
right
yes exactly exactly so it's been very
important
um it just didn't you know really cannot
be overstated and interestingly actually
just before I came on air I noticed
um that Elon Musk had tweeted to say how
he was very happy to provide this
support
um I think it was a Ukrainian I didn't
quite notice who but I think as a
Ukrainian official was thanking
um musk for the importance of starlink
to their success and musk said that he
was very happy to sort of play his part
in their success so I don't know if if
this Twitter storm has chastened him he
doesn't seem like the sort of individual
that's easily chastened so um but in any
case I mean to come back to the the
debate of course it's a little bit he
says he says so it's very difficult but
on on another level I mean Mr grandma is
um you know this isn't some sort of
random sub stack that he's running you
know he speaks to very serious people
and I I do find it quite hard to imagine
he would just make up a conversation
yeah and we do have you know full
disclosure we asked Ian to come on the
program tonight
um he has agreed he said I can't do it
tonight but he says I will come on the
program and talk with you about this
which we believe because as I said he's
been on many times before let me ask you
before we run out of time there was a
U.N general assembly vote on this
evening about Russia's recent
annexations of territory in eastern
Ukraine overwhelming condemnation of
Russia in that vote
um
is Russia going to Care is it going to
change anything on the ground
[Music]
to the point
that the difficult
that we have with the UN when you have a
member of the U.N security Council
um like Russia sort of you know
committing the sort of atrocities that
it is committing it's it's very
difficult to see the current setup of
the UN as as anything but
highly dysfunctional
Jade McLean from the Monterey initiative
in Russian studies
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight a lot of ground to
cover and we did that thank you
thank you